tonight another closer look at nevada
ahead of the november midterms so our
exclusive eight news now emerson college
the hill poll shows the main races are
really tight they're also signs that the
issues which matter the most are
actually shifting politics now host john
langler explains
what do nevadans care about what could
drive voters to the polls in 55 days
while one issue rises above the rest new
laws and rulings are changing the
landscape first let's get this out of
the way we do have the top issue that's
the economy spencer kimball is executive
director of emerson college polling it
comes as no surprise to him the economy
matters most to nevadans nearly 42
percent of those we polled are voting
based on the economy that's around nine
percent higher than our poll in july
abortion comes in second an issue
kimball says is driving the democratic
vote on the democratic side it's
abortion access on the republican side
we see the search of mar largo as a
motivator another big issue our
decreasing water supply nearly 90
percent call it either very or somewhat
serious however there is another split
on education issues 39 percent support
using public money for vouchers for
private schools 33 percent are against
while 18 percent are undecided and polls
show 60 percent of nevadans are against
president biden's new student loan
forgiveness plan the mail vote is
breaking for republicans the female vote
is breaking for the democrats and we'll
see if either side is able to coalesce
the other group over in the next seven
eight weeks john langler 8 news now